اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول
اشهد ان محمد
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
بسم الله
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم
الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى
في كتابه الكريم
امر المؤمنين
وليعف
وليصفحوا
الا تحبون ان يغفر الله لكم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
and
‏B of brotherhood
the prop time
was
عبد الله ابي ابن سلول
of منافقين
‏that would go around to different
gather andate
and imply
and articulate so many without coming
out and
that
was unff
our prop صلى الله عليه
‏He didn't say it right out that.
He didn't say she did X, Y and Z.
He just insinuated it which oftentimes
can be much worse
than just coming out and saying
something.
‏gather
people
would
you what happ
you know i don't want to say anything i
don't want to say anything about anyone
but this is what i don't know
and he would insinuate
‏of prop
and spread among the hypocrites like
wildfire
and it caused a big rift but it was
superficial among the believer
the maor
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏inocating
all any
and so it was
however some bad bl lingered
andஷ
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
ابو بكر رضي الله
‏and unforun
he gotcked
to
these
and so
was
by
صلى الله عليه
‏accuses
of such a thing he is to bring witnesses
three including himself and if he is
unable to produce said witnesses they
are to be floged publicly 80 times
and so he was flogged
‏thinkes
wh
is what is called a small whip or a bull
whip and the scholars tell us that the
flogging
is to never include
[Silence]
‏and was
and
taking and punishment he was cleared
because you cann punish someone
to blame that person simultane
بكر
ممد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مدين ابو بكر
‏time was
everything
but this came out accused accus
and friendly
عليه الصلاه والسلام
ابو بكر
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
‏that those of great
and those among you
generity
ولا
they are not by Allah
that they will not give those areess
fortunate they will never
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وليعفوا وليصفحوا
الا تحبون ان يغفر الله
‏are
and are paron
do you not all desire
forgives and pardons you
this is point here
that someone
accused your daughter of such a thing
someone accused
‏someadful
rors
and tainted your daughter, your mother,
your sister,
your tainted your honor
and you have always been good to this
person.
‏about the hand that feed you
and did what we would
never give you
thisay
الله سبحانه وتالى said
you are never to use আল্লাহ name
as a
‏name
الله
why
this is not tre
‏because
for that's why
and so we learn from this ver
that a more
general rule of thumb if you will a yard
stick
and that is that you will be tre by
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فمن احب ان يزحزح عن النار
ويدخل الجنه
فلتاته منيته
وهو يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر
ولياتي الى الناس الذي يحب ان يؤتى اليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
desires
to be shieldedoved
from the fire and admitted into parad
is to him while he is in a state of
belief in Allah in the last day and he
brings unto others what he wishes
‏our time
become more difficult
because we era of wolves
we have human beings with the hearts of
devils
in the form of human beings walking
aroundilling up and occ
‏usy
minority among
the last
those not
the quر as anything more
than the
you know make
‏And so the more
the more predatory
people become
the more the me
and the good
and the dutful
and the generous and the merful will be
exped. ‏is a
if you want to be good and a world of
wolves, you need to prepare yourself
because you are going to get picked
apart.
‏But does that stop us?
Does that change our trajectory? No. We
are more desperate today for good men
and women to be good men and women than
any other time before.
‏If the earth is filled
with animals and you are to be the only
believer, then you are to do it and hold
your head up high whil.
‏Because we don't do what good because
popular
and don't
because
anything
good because are
that is why
in today's world
people boast about being
having the worst of traits.
‏of in poety
to be arrogant
we call that driven arrogance is dri
and dutiful
is
and
last
in today's in poy
isolishness
الله سبحانه وتالى
are
الله سبحانه وتعالى ديسكرايب
ياتي بقوم يحبهم ويحبونه
اذله على المؤمنين
اعز على الكافرين
يجاهدون في سبيل الله ولا يخافون لوملائم
‏the most
and of the
those loves and they in love him
who are those individuals
they are those who are gentle with the
believer
firm with the disbelieving
and they are not hinder
‏by
those are
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول ان من وراء كم ايام الصبر
الصبر فيهن مثل قبض على الجمر
للمتمسك
فيهن
بما انتم عليه اليوم
اجروا 50 رجلا منكم
قالوا يا رسول الله منا اي من الصحابه ام
منهم قال بل منكم
انتم ايها الصحابه اسمعوا الاوصاف
ايام الصبر سماها
الصبر فيهن مثل قبض على الجمر
للمتمسك فيهن في تلك الايام
للمتمسك فيهن بما انتم ايها الصحابه عليه
اليوم اجر 50 رجلا منكم
قالوا منا ام منهم قال بل منكم
صلى الله عليه
‏said these are
being patient and holding to yourigion
during such times is trying to
clasp your fist around lits.
You take a lit amber and you squeeze it.
‏prop صلى الله عليه
‏for those
to you all are speaking to the companion
he said for those and wom those
believing brothers and sisters during
those days of patience
those who are holding to that which you
all are upon today
is the reward of 50 men amongst you the
companion ‏said 50 men amongst us or
amongst them? He said 50 men amongst you
doesn't mean in everything the reward of
50 men 50 companions in everything
but the reward of 50 companions in the
element of patience holding to the truth
in spite
of unpularity
‏because
era of the
wasable to be
it was
it was the en of the world's nations to
be
they were at the helm of society and
humanity
‏edovit
those days easy to be a easy to be good
but in a day
when the truthful is looked at with
accusing eye
‏and
is tr
on the days
is deem treous and the treous are deem
trustwthy
during the days of patience
it's very difficult to be that good
person it's very difficult to be a good
man or woman
it's very difficult to
‏If you are
among peopleesty
if you are among the people of impurity
if you are straight in era of
crookedness
if you are dutiful ‏in era
of
in of treachery
if you are generous in the epic
of stinginess and misery
you will be taken advantage of there's
no way around it
there's no way around it and that is not
a shamme
that is what makes being good in a
‏by
immediats.
You have a higher code,
a higher book that you turn to, and a
higher that you answer to.
‏You're not good because it yields
results. You're not generous
becauseelying
on the thankfulness and gratitude of
those who earn your generity.
You're not dutiful because people are
dful to you.
You are dful because this is something
that Allah.
‏You are gener because you look for your
reward with Allah.
‏You are strong upon your de and you
tell the truth not becauseields
immedi
but becauseields
the almighty
the king of kings the judge of judges
that is the high order that the muslwers
to
and you will be
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه
انه هو الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد حميد مجيد اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم كفر عنا سيئاتنا
اللهم توفنا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما
وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد اللهم اننا نسالك فعل
الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين وان
تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت
بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا
وتوفنا اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم
اجعل القران العظيم ربيع قلوبنا ونور
صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا ربنا
علمنا منهما جهلنا وذكرنا منهما نسينا
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من
جهد البلاء ودرك الشقاء وسوء القضاء
وشماته الاعداء اللهم اننا نسالك عيش
السعداء ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء اللهم
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك
والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في غزه
وفلسطين وفي كل مكان اللهم انصرهم على
عدوهم اللهم اجعل ثارهم على من ظلمهم
اللهم انصرهم على عدوهم اللهم عليك
باعدائك
اعداء الدين اللهم اننا نجعلك في نحورهم
ونجعلك في نحورهم ونعوذ بك من شرورهم
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيوني المحتل
اللعين اللهم بكته تبكيتا اللهم ردهم
خائبين مخزيين اللهم
اضرب عليهم الذله والهوان واقطع الحبال
بينهم وبين العباد اللهم زلزل اركانهم
اللهم صدع بنيانهم اللهم اقتل اجنادهم
اللهم افضحهم يا رب العالمين اللهم ارنا
فيهم عجائب قدرتك اللهم اقتلهم قتل عاد
وارم
اجعل احياءهم في ذل وخزي وهوان واجعل
قتلاهم يتقلبون في النيران اللهم امين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استووادوا
shoulders
[Silence]
‏All
pleas
الله
اكبر سبحانك اللهم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
والعصر ان
الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ويل لكل همزه لمزه
ويل لكل همزه لمزه الذي جمع مالا وعددا
يحسب ان ماله
اخلده كلا
لينبذن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراكما الحطمه
نار الله الموقده التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم
مؤصده
في عمد
ممدده
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
صلاه
الفجر
صلاه العشاء
صلاه الفجر 4:30
صلاه العشاء 9
الله ‏Pleas
notrive your
people
as
donate generously
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
كم
حياك
[Silence]
السلام